نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشفت مصادر
العربيه انا شركه طيران معراج الايراني
المرتبطه بالحرس الثوري تسير رحلات لمطار
بيروت وبيانات النار رحلات الشركه
الايرانيه الى لبنان قد تنقل اسلحه ومعدات
حساسه لحزب الله مشيرتان الى ان استغلال
مطار بيروت في نقل اسلحه ايرانيه للبنان
سيضروا بالاقتصاد اللبناني وقد يعرض لبنان
للعقبات والعزله كما اشارت المصادر لان
اول رحله لشركه مع رجل ايرانيه الى مطار
بيروت كانت في الرابع عشر من نوفمبر
الماضي
ولفتت مصادر العربيه الى ان اسرائيل تخشن
امام مطار بيروت الى مسار تهريب الاسلحه
من ايران للبنان وقالت المصادر انها رحلته
شركه معراج الايرانيه تهبط بشكل اسبوعي في
مطار دمشق الدولي وكانت اسرائيل سهمت حزب
الله في نقل اسلحه ايراني للبنان عبر
رحلات مدنيه هبطت في مطار دمشق الدولي
[موسيقى]
منافس هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بيروت
العميد خالد حماده
سيد علي الامين ما مدى دقه ما يروج بخصوص
هذه شركه شركه طيران التي يقول البعض
بانها توصل اسلحه حساسه لحزب الله هل من
دلائل فعليه تؤكد هكذا منطق
بدايه تحياتي لك ولي المشاهدين العربيه
ولضيف الكريم اللي عم خالد اييه يعني على
الاقل لنتحدث بالبيانات الرسميه
يعني واضح انه مدير الطيران المدني وايضا
يعني نفع وجود مثل هذا التهريب او السلاح
وخاصه على هذه الطائره وزير الداخليه تجول
في المطار لم يحدد موقف همم يعني واضح
تماما لكن قال ان هناك اجراءات امنيه
وهناك عمل امني وهناك حرص على عدم يعني ان
يكون مطار بيروت مع بار لي تهريب سواء من
من مطار بيروت او الى همم الى همم داخل
لبنان همم لكن هذا بطبيعه الحال لا يقلل
من السؤال الاساسي يعني اذا سالتي اي
مواطن لبناني اليوم هل لديك ثقه بان هذه
مطار او حتى كما حصل اصلا في مرفا بيروت
يعني مرفا بيروت كان هيا اجري الحديث عن
انه لا شيء يمر عبر مرفا بيروت وهو مطلوب
وتفاجانا اخيرا عن وجود النترات بمطار
بيروت ايضا ليس هناك من ثقه على الاقل ده
المواطن اللبناني نحن ليس لدينا معلومات
دقيقه حتى نتحدث عن ان حصل تهريب في هذا
التوقيت
العام لدى المواطنين لا ثقه
عميد حماده
وصلت الطائره اللبنانيه واكتشفنا في اليوم
الثاني انه هذه المطار السلاح وصل الى حزب
الله سيقول الكثيرون في لبنان لانه هذا
عامر طبيعي يعني يصل سلاح لحزب الله لانه
سلاح حزب الله يخضع همم هناك نوع من قبول
وتش له على الاقل بالبيان الوزاري انه هذا
سلاح للمقاومه بدا امر يعني يحصل في لبنان
بشكل همم يعني همم
اذا كان يعني كشف شيء ما سيقال انه هذا
شيء همم طبيعي وغير وبالتالي اذا لم يكشف
سيبقى الامر في حاله الغموض وما الى ذلك
لكن حسبي الله يصل وهو سلعه من خارج لبنان
واخص وحزب الله لا يصنع اسلحه هو يستورد
اسلحه وبالتالي هذا السلاح كيف يدخل مطار
بيروت يمكن ان يكون معبر من المراه لكن في
المعابر اخرى ايضا
يصل هذا الامر همم السؤال الاساسي هل
حزب الله
طائره خاصه ولكننا نحن نتحدث عن طيران
مدني عائلات همم تستعمل هذا النوع من
الطيران للسفر همم عميد
قالت كيف يتم تهريب اسلحه عن طريق شركه
طيران مدني ضيف يقول بان هذا يمكن ان يكون
شبه طبيعي همم لن تكون هناك مفاجاه اذا
تاكد ذلك همم كيف
مساء الخير يعني اولا
لننظر الى همم فعلا هل هناك في ايران اي
مؤسس همم مدنيه او حكوميه خارج دائره
التاثير للحرس الثوري الايراني هل يستطيع
احد الفصل بين الشركات المدنيه شركات
طيران المدنيه في طيران وشركات النقل
العسكريه في السباحه استخدامها من قبل
الحرس الثوري الايراني طبعا الجواب لا اذا
يعني كل شيء في ايران هو همم خدمه
المنظومه الحاكمه ومنظومه الميليشيات
وتوزعها طبعا في العالم العربي اين مكان
اذا الشك دائما موجود كما قال الاستاذ علي
السؤال الاخر يعني انه لماذا هناك دائما
اجراءات خاصه للطائرات الايرانيه بمعنى
انه جوازات السفر لا يتم ختمها في مطار
بيروت بل يتم ختم فقط بطاقات الدخول
هذا لماذا تدخل الدوله اللبنانيه في هذا
التدبير ويعني يروج انه هذا التدبير ليس
فقط للمسافرين الايرانيين يعني نحن ندرك
انه في لبنان يعني لا اعتقد انه هناك شريك
عميد عميد حماده لا افهم هذا التفصيل لمن
ليس لبناني وليس ايراني لماذا لا تختم
جوازات سفر لماذا تختم فقط بطاقات الدخول
همم
يعني الفكره اولا انه هذا اولا خدم جواز
السفر بمعنى ان هذا الجواز اذا اذا استعمل
في مكان اخر ستعلم السلطات ان هذا الشخص
قد دخل الى مطار بيروت يعني لماذا التعنيه
على دخوله هؤلاء الاشخاص الى مطار بيروت
اذا كان هؤلاء هم اشخاص عاديون يعني ياتون
الى بيروت للسياحه او للعمل او للزيارات
معينه اذا لماذا يعني هذه التعنيه على
زيارتهم لبيروت يعني لماذا هذا الاجراء
الذي فعلا اذا لم يكن يعني يخفي خلفيه
امنيا فاذا لماذا نقوم به يعني ولماذا هي
جوازات السفر ولماذا هي سمات الدخول يعني
سواء الفوريه التي تمنع على المطار او
التي تملح باجراءات معينه
هذه الطائرات يعني حاول وزير الداخليه انه
هذه المشنوق عندما كان وزير الداخليه ان
يلغي هذه الاجراءات ولكن ذلك لم يتم يعني
يعني
والسبب او ال ال
ال الراي الوجيه في الموضوع لماذا نضع
لبنان يعني في شبكه الاتهام اذا كان فعلا
لا يوجد هناك اي انشطه غير
هذا يعني عميد حماده الموضوع مش حتى شبكه
اتهام موضوع قد يكون همم اخطر من ذلك يعني
منذ قليل الاستاذ علي قرب بين ما يمكن ان
يحدث وبين ما حدث في بيروت وهنا السؤال
استاذ علي حتى لا يعيش لبنان نفس الكارثه
مع الاسف حتى يدرك همم
نفسه في وقت مبكر همم ما الذي يمكن او من
المسؤول عن التفتيش وعن متابعه هذا
الموضوع
يعني نحن مع الاسف في لبنان
يعني خلينا نقول انه اذا نظرنا لما حصل في
المرفا فن نرى انه تقاذف المسؤوليات يعني
رمي المسؤوليه كلهم على الاخر
ويبدو احيانا وكان نحن في مجموعه دول وهذا
اسلوب من اساليب الحكم لبناني يعني يعني
هذا ليس عفويه ولا يتم همم ان الظروف
فرضته ولكن هي وسيله من وسيله السيطره على
لبنان وحكم لبنان بانه ان يكون هناك
الفاعل غير واضح وبالتالي في امكانيه
دائما لرمي المسؤوليه على اكثر من شخص من
دون ان تتحدث في نهايه الامر المسؤوليه
بطبيعه الحال اذا يطرح سؤال اساسي من
المسؤول في مطار بيروت سيتحدث البعض ان
هناك جهاز امن المطار ان هناك الامن العام
انه هناك الجيش اللبناني ربما قال له دور
كذا كل ادت اجهزه موجوده في مطار بيروت
ولكن في حصول لا سمح الله اي حادث معين
نجد ان كل طرف يحاول ان يرمي المسؤوليه
على طرف اخر وبالتالي لابد من قرار سياسي
واضح ان لم يحسم هذا القرار السياسي يعني
على مستوى السلطه ويكون امر نهائي وثابت
ولا جدال فيه انه لا سلطه الا سلطه الدوله
بمعنى ان ليس هناك ليس مسموحا لاي جهه
مهما بلغت اهميتها في لبنان ان تستخدم
المرافق الرسميه لمصالحها الخاصه سواء
لتهريب سلاح او ل- اا لامور اخرى وبالتالي
طالما ان الامر غير محسوب
فقط يعني استاذه ان يكون اكيد بانه هناك
شركاء في العمليه يعني اليوم حزب الله
صحيح باعضاء في البرلمان مثلا هو حاضر في
همم الصوره السياسيه في لبنان ولكن همم هل
يعقل وهنا سؤال لك عميد حماده هل يمكن
لحزب الله ان يتصرف بطريقه احاديه ان صح
طبعا هذه هي التسريبات
شركاء في داخل اللبناني
اولا لا حسبي الله يتسرب بطريقه احديه وهو
فعليا ليس لديه شركاء بمعنى الشركاء
النديديين هو لديه حلفاء يفرض عليهم ما
يريد تبعا لمصالح سياسيه ترتبط بهم
وبالتالي حزب الله لا يشارك في قراره
الامني اي جهه لبنانيه هو لا يهمه الشراكه
او لا يابا بان يقبل احد يعني همم ما يقوم
به امنيا في لبنان ثاني يعني مطار بيروت
وكما يعني اريد ان اضيف على ما تقدم به
الاستاذ علي يعني فعلا جهاز امن المطار في
لبنان يتبع اداريا لوزير الداخليه
وتتمثل فيه كل الاجهزه الامنيه ولكن كل
جهاز يتبع لرئاسه المباشر وبالتالي هناك
فوضى في تحديد المسؤوليه وكذلك دائما يعني
تتاثر فعاليه الاجهزه في مطار بيروت
بمقدار فعاليه الاجهزه في الخارج او يعني
اداه هذه الاجده في الخارج وبالتالي
القرار الامن هو في مكان ما قرار ما يطبقه
احيانا جهاز امن المطار او في اغلب الحاله
جهاز امن المطار لصالح حزب الله لان حزب
الله كما يهايمن على السياسه يهيمن
بالتالي على الاجهزه الامنيه التي ترتبط
بالاداره السياسيه يعني
ثم لكي نضع هذه الانشطه يعني في اطارها
الصحيح سبق ان يعني تسربت عده معلومات ان
طائرات ايرانيه حضرت الى مطار بيروت ونقلت
اجهزه تحديد الموقع ليصار الى تثبيتها على
صواريخ موجوده اساسا في مخازن حزب الله او
سبق ان نقلت اشخاص يعني هم قاده في
الميليشيات وفي الحشد الشعبي الى بيروت
ليجروا اجتماعات او من الحوثيين في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه او ربما لنقل المدربين
وسما يعني دون ان يكون للسلطه الرسميه اي
تاثير على ذلك اذا هناك يعني هناك دوله
موازيه في السياسه ودوله موازيه في
الاقتصاد هناك دوله موازيه في الامن بما
يتعلق بالامكنه والانشطه التي تعني الاله
العسكريه والام
نيه وبالتالي وبالتالي يعني الشك في محله
ولكن المخاطره ان تكمل يعني اذا اختلفت
الحسابات الدوليه واذا كان هناك نوع من
اعاده ترتيب النفوذ ان يستعمل هذه
المعلومات كما يحصل في مطار دمشق او في
مطارات اخرى في سوريا ان تتعرض فعلا بني
تحتيه لمطار بيروت اولي اماكن اخرى لعمليه
قصف يعني وبالنهايه يدفع يعني لبنان فمن
اضافيه من همم اضافيا على الاسنان التي
يدفعها طبعا في السياسه وفي العزله
الدبلوماسيه والانهيار الاقتصادي يعني
ندخل لبنان في حلقه مخاطره عاليه طبعا
لانشطه ليست غازات قيمه هي انشطه هادفه
يعني عندما تاتي الطائره
حتى يتحمل لبنان هذه المخاطر ويحمل حزب
الله لبنان كل هذه المخاطر استاذ علي ما
نوعيه الاسلحه ما الذي يمكن ان ان يكون اا
او تكون همم هذه الشركات هادئ همم شركات
الطيران الايرانيه هذه ان ترسله او تدخله
لحزب الله
يعني شبكه التعاون الامني والعسكري شبكي
واحده هي اساسا يعني يعني حزب الله لا
يمكن وصفه باعتباره مجرد همم يعني جهاز
عسكري امني في في لبنان همم يتلقى دعم من
طرف اخر لا هو امتداد طبيعي
للاذرع الايراني والحرس الثوري وبطبيعه
الحال فهناك منظومه مشتركه متكامل بالتالي
تحت هذه العنوان هناك جمله امور اساسيه
يعني كثيره ما تحدث همم حزب الله عن تطوير
اسلحه معينه تتعلق بطائرات المسيره تتعلق
بالصواريخ تتعلق بامكانيه وجود مصانع
معينه في لبنان فبالتالي يمكن ان يكون
هناك نقل لاجهزه دقيقه لا يمكن يعني ان
همم يعني همم لا تثير الشبهه ربما باحجام
ليست كبيره تتحدث عن لا نتحدث عن ذائر بس
ربما تجهيزات همم
امورتينيه معينه لها علاقه
همم علاقه بالاسلحه التي
الطائرات او ما الى ذلك المسيره او ربما
بهذا الوجه لانه طائره مدنيه لا يمكن ان
تنقل بطبيعه الحال ذخائر وربما ليس هناك
من حاجه لنقل الذخائر عبر طائره مدنيه
فاذا الحديث عن اسلحه نوعيه ذات قيمه همم
معينه تقنيه وبالتالي همم سهل نقلها
بطريقه او باخرى خاصه انه مطار بيروت ايضا
هناك قدره على تمريره الكثير من همم يعني
ما هو ينخل الى مطار بيروت بوسائل همم من
خارج همم دائره الجمارك وما الى ذلك وذلك
يمكن ان يبرر تحت عنوان كالقول ان هذه
امور متعلقه بالمقاومه وما الى ذلك نحن
نعلم في لبنان انه طالما ان هناك اسمها
المقاومه فيمكن ان تمرر اي شيء لا يستطيع
احد ان همم يتدخل في هذا الامر وهذا معروف
لدى الاجهزه الامنيه لاجهزه العسكريه
استاذ علي اشياء كثيره في هذا الصباح يقول
منذ قليل العميد حماده همم تقول منذ قليل
بان هذا الموضوع ليس منفصل عن مواضع اخرى
ذات صله ترتبط بتهريب الاسلحه عن طريق
الطيران المدني وتحدثت عن شراك مكتمله بين
الحرس الثوري وايران فيما تستخدم لبنان
الى جانب ايصال الاسلحه عميد حماده
عفوا لما يستخدم لبنان في اي مجالات اخرى
يستخدم لبنان لهذه الشراكه العسكريه بين
الجانبين الى جانب موضوع تهريب الاسلحه
يعني يعني اولا نحن نعلم انه
يعني الملفات الايرانيه الشائكه مع كل
العالم وتحديدا حاله التوتر التي تعيشها
ايران اليوم حاله العزله ااه يعني هذا
يشكل حافزا لاستخدام الساحه اللبنانيه
ربما الاعمال توجه ضد دول معينه او ضد
مصالح معينه في داخل اللبناني كوسيله ضغط
على قرار لدوله ما لتغيير موقفها من ايران
وكذلك يعني هناك الموضوع الاسرائيلي الذي
طارت يعني تعلو وتيره التوتر بين اسرائيل
وحزب الله وايران وتارتا نشعر بان هناك
نوع من المهادنه ومراعات للمصالح
المتبادله على قاعده ما جرى في الترسيم
البحري اذا يعني يستحيل حصر كل هذه
الاهداف
باستنتاج واحد
حزب الله في النهايه هو احد الاذرع
الايرانيه الموجوده في لبنان التي تستطيع
ان تقوم بكل الانشطه وفق ما تريد دون اي
مجابهه من اي جهه رسميه لبنانيه
لضيق الوقت هو الوقت انتهى تماما الخاص
بهذا الملف ولكن ستبقى عيننا على تطوراتهم
من بيروت علي الامين رئيس تحرير موقع
الجنوبيه وكذلك ضيفنا همم خالد حماده
الباحث في شؤون الامنيه والسياسيه السلام
عليكم